being single is hard during the holidays
but if you can't find a boyfriend you
can assemble one in just a few easy
steps with DIY bf step 1 purchase the
DIY bf starter kit so a big renovation
project oh yeah I know I'm pretty handy
I could come over tonight maybe you
don't really busy I have to get started
on this thank you though
next constructor customised boyfriend
with the help of a friend or neighbor so
what's all this for anyways oh I'm a
building a boyfriend to take to my
office holiday party oh yeah I want a
date for mine I don't know if you're
free but how you not really they have to
finish this if you could just now go to
your doctor's office and ask for a DNA
swab ink it still single that's good cuz
I've been meaning to ask you yes I would
like to have my antidepressants next
collected DNA sample from a man you'd
find attractive why won't you just go on
a date with me then during a full moon
boil the DNA with two ox phones a frog
and a handful of human hair sprinkle in
the ashes of an absent father figure and
bring to a boil put the brew under your
pillow wake up the next morning and meet
your handsome new boyfriend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now take your DIY boyfriend to the
holiday party and make all your
co-workers jealous oh yeah we have my
boyfriend I'm Mac DIY bf is sponsored by
de practice' a new antidepressant and
clinical trial side effects may include
hallucinations breaks with reality with
attachment to objects repeating a
behavior over and over again in
splinters ask your doctor if X is right
for you
[Applause]
you